hello hello everyone and welcome to the
joy con of cooking if you haven't heard
the music yet we are going to be playing
overcooked today yeah I am Joey this is
John Luke stop and we're going to be
happy Friday y'all happy Friday
glad you could join us on earth to coals
get right into that Friday streams here
I adore this game's music why are you we
already hooked them up though okay
that's one more time there we go okay
well that's fine yeah it's very very
very sad yes the sense now yesterday and
it comes with everything so the campaign
and the two DLC packs The Lost morsel
and the festive seasons how much
overcooked if you play
I actually I didn't beat the main game
played a little bit of a lost morsel
already let's switch no no no like on a
ps4 well yeah we played it all last
quick so if we can maybe do it in the
chat if you guys want to ask any
questions I will be reading it or I'll
be trying to read it as much as possible
while plane AB says well okay we're
gonna be start from the beginning
yeah I did the little quick tutorial
thing over there just to get past that
but we're gonna just get right into this
okay yeah changing by my cooks oh yeah
you don't have any of the cool chefs
unlock like a cat guy I'll be wait this
dude
all right well what's the - button
- button yes have a - right I don't
think so no they do remember that I make
basic soup now I make basic soup don't
add me overcooked okay it's it's the
this is down one okay so we got a chop
all right okay gotta get back on the
group of this alright um I can tell this
is already starting to it's already
starting bad okay well yep
I will say the the original game had a
little imprecise nature to it your
YouTube chopping I'm gonna okay grab you
get so use the island right here yeah we
gotta get a system we're already being
horribly inefficient okay plate when you
get a chance you talk about this is this
is going fairly well I think right nope
the the imprecise control the first game
had some imprecise controls I thought
were like sometimes I was wanting to do
something and it wouldn't let me still
feels like the case here like they
haven't improved that I don't know I
feel like it maybe it's kind of like
supposed to be that way I don't know
sometimes for it's like I'm just trying
to grab a thing and it like won't let me
or I grab like a thing next to it young
guy oh and chat says hello Joey and
jelly
hello to you oh try to reach as much as
possible while chopping all these onion
right gonna be a little more difficult
than usual LT tasking whoops
yeah more onions I'll just load load up
those onions okay
OOP I need a plate there's one in the
sink there we go Oh smack me hey there
you could do that what's the sprint
button it's a just be or what it was a
down button hook it down for me gotta
use a switch language here the down
button a weird thing to say right cuz
then they start just pressing the pen oh
yeah but it's like the yeah I don't know
I do appreciate how Julie soups boiling
all right it's ready but I'm hearing
that I'm feeling an HD Rumble yeah so a
couple issues I had with this we only
have one pot and I have one pot yeah
that's the issue okay here's the pot
okay this games got HD Rumble in it and
it's a little a little extra for me like
all too much I find if I like here
through the the microphones here yes but
it's a bit much
so I wonder if this way you can turn off
that force that one's ready
probably get oh shoot Oh Joey maybe make
it oh boy oh boy
put it there put it in my hands I got oh
no Joey yep go go go sprint sprint
sprint sprint yeah how do we do 130 I'm
not sure what that equates to three
stars is sick new chef
that dude mr. dick splash says I'm
hungry I am too actually had any
breakfast I was like walking by like I
gotta get to the stream and I saw the
pile of bagels we haven't like so I did
you played the entire game on it with
two people right two players why how is
that actually it's awesome by compared
to four you can certainly do four it's a
bit chaotic I found two is a really fun
manageable way to play this game you
definitely can't play you can play okay
you can play this game single-player I
wouldn't not wreck that I find it very
it's the most cumbersome bullying okay
this time tomatoes feel like I should be
doing more here okay what do you got we
got mostly onions yeah tomatoes whoa
okay sure did I hit a button give me I
guess take that
put it on wait but in put enjoy oh oh
see is what I'm talking about Oh give me
soup all right take it off the burner oh
boy another oh we need another onion
that's why yeah right you just grab more
stuff in no this one's done okay you got
any more onions or no yeah having some
Spanos sorry okay I'm gonna play this
souped-up
oh boy dishwasher yeah we'll get this
tomato Thanks do we want to have a
dedicated chopper that's kind of yeah
it's like everyone rolls here in the
middle of everything you kind of just
get like okay right now hand me stuff
kind of just find yourself in front of
like bask you that you're ready to go or
the soup pot and you just have to do
something
oh man the dishes need to be washed yep
okay I got this okay cold yeah finally
why are we letting people walk in
between our cooking this is terrible
design food trucks you just opened we
need it's like a food truck except it's
just on the street that's right
oh boy I have nothing else to give you
more onion Joey
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Liz if there is a waffle at any
point during this I will make a
reference to it right in there get it
lot of tomatoes oh crap
onions ready no dishes see with like
four people you can have like a
dedicated dishwasher again you can do
whatever in this where am I
sy you don't run no one in the kitchen
oh okay you made a soup yeah I got it by
the way a hot soup
alright I'm gonna clean and maybe we can
get one more lead here yeah yeah nore
okay we definitely got that one I don't
know if we can get any more I don't
think so we got like 20 seconds one more
super Oh haven't you think you can spill
it Tomatoes
yeah we're not gonna make it
nope 162 is a is a respectable medal
right hey as long as you get three stars
consigning yeah three stars I don't know
if you've noticed I feel the game is a
bit um
[Music]
sluggish sluggish yeah actually it feels
like their performance is not quite as
good as it was on the ps4 yeah not that
bad you tend to see that I feel like
it's just maybe not optimized great
because the okay go back yeah I can also
choose apparently I can't drive though
[Music]
why is it suddenly offering four people
I have no idea what's going on all right
let's go
yeah I thought the the his for version
like ran a little bit better and I I'm
sure it did look could just be a mistake
uh oh sorry my cousin in the chat says
they thought their game ran at 30 frames
per second I don't actually remember
remember I just remember it being not
quite as like little bit smoother yeah
exactly
not that it like this which could
absolutely handle this game I mean if
you can run splatoon at 6 frames per
second right 1080 it's just not been
optimized oh this is the one that slides
yeah yeah I will get to the other side
in preparation all right go here on that
side now Kevin ball stay on that side
grab that grab that uh yep cool else do
you need
damn pusher convenient onion all right
get in there Jerry look okay right take
those onions
plate that thank you here you go
cannonbolt us in the foot look I'm doing
all the heavy lifting here okay swap
swap the onion I got it Oh
mush but where's I keep happening
connectivity issues I'll have to switch
the pro controllers at some folding labs
we have Pro controllers all right you
got a plate that suit
yeah got this okay all right you got we
got nine Tomatoes worth of soup -
awesome coming up get a little swap Joey
yeah there you go I need some clean
plates yeah I gotcha I gotcha
also more more Tomatoes soups ready
keep delivered
you bet they're round we're on top of it
get it and they're all right
that simple be ready in the sack I mean
he's coming up mmm yeah this is it's
going very well
say I want to get to the good stuff yeah
get to the hard like burgers and pizza
oh I'll get back
my doing mushroom
ow I had a chili
it needs a plate stay in your lane Joey
Oh JJ stomach and B I'm the one frantic
cook who never stay calm
we need these all right give me a plate
for that mushroom oh this you could
adjust oh I got it I got it I realize
there's no sink here either so we have
me washing dishes yeah nice seconds gone
[Music]
two stars by six points we failed it
dang it it's fine you look unlock the
cats cat chef
where are we going ooh Oh aye aye aye I
have no idea to pronounce this person's
name you just say the boss the boss says
I love you GameSpot I love you too
thank you some nuclear reactors here
let's go on petroleum sure this Angeles
says this game looks awesome yeah you
should definitely if you have not played
overcooked yet
you should definitely play it's pretty
much on every system yeah in this game
is where I'm gonna be back at ya oopss
feels alright what just one joy con
control wise yeah I mean it's just the
controls of this game are very simple
you don't have to use like those yeah
it's just like everything yes Ron
burgers and I don't know like I my hands
are tiny so joy calms don't bother me
that much the weight some people do but
like I wish I had the the strap thing
that weasel ooh I'm gonna cut meat okay
Joey here's what you can do you can put
plates on or you can put buns on plates
ahead of time
oh yeah
and then get that meat sizzling as well
as I have six a while yeah yeah don't
worry you're good you're good okay
they're not gonna just order something
like a bun without any meat right don't
worry I have meat whoops yeah yeah okay
the first one is nothing yep I got it
it's in you don't worry about that oh
here you chop I'm gonna start plating
okay we're gonna squat here okay
tomatoes come on individually yep okay
I'm gonna take a walk that one requires
both okay they all have lettuce for the
next four they all have lettuce
I'll have lettuce okay give me yeah okay
that lettuce the first ones done though
okay done second it's done
next one I'm taking the lid off the
floor no one saw me just lettuce
we need more meats
the frying pan I gotta chop the meat
damn it
yeah here you need to focus on that I'm
going to clean dishes Joey Joey this is
how I act in my kitchen today in my
kitchen we move that at a brisk pace we
take our time we're polite dashing
through everything I got I got it
alright alright and then the next one
has the bun and then then get the
lettuce yeah I got it clean these dishes
get your cleaning dishes I'm going to
get more meat gube unfortunately we do
not get points for smacking people or we
would be we have a high score
all right you start serving that up
someone to check we know I'm sorry if I
pronounce your name if we're playing on
switch but the game is available on
pretty much all consoles right now
pretty sure it's on ps4 PMO originally
it's on PC as well
yep he's on xbox I want to say yes I'll
have two percent but I can't imagine it
wouldn't be ouch okay I need another
plate I don't have one go clean yourself
busy chopping vegetables here alright
fine alright get lettuce it's weird that
I can feel the vibration the vibration
when you're cleaning the dishes yeah
that's a bit weird okay do we can I
don't get lettuce get loaded I do do do
here just serve it sir it there's just
one available just serve it yeah okay
yeah one more
nevermind oh don't if you I grabbed a
bun we could have actually served two if
that's dang in 280 man oh whatever
yeah show us controls every time we know
what we're doing and originally when we
had first planned this live stream we
had thought about using one joke on like
sherry because that's the thing you can
do on my ps3 and ps4 ps4 but thinking
about it I was like wait a minute
there's not enough buttons on the joy
comes yeah do that I was like you can
use the d-pad we could play one person
and be like but that would be like a
nightmare I think that I'm doing it no
one would find that fun
okay oh yeah this one's got the one-lane
so you have to stay and kind of no no
something allowed Joey well I'm just
gonna be pushing you the down you're
wearing me around I'm like Joey just go
around it's easier Chris crisis yes is
it actually released yesterday I believe
20 miles to the switch and that comes
with all the DLC that they released so
far which is that that's dude seasoning
and this to me put them down and put
them down here yeah
oh we got mushrooms yeah just lay them
all out those festive season and the
lost morsel or the two DLC packs that
also come with game okay okay we don't
need that
[Music]
Oh chop that tomato please shut up
thank you Bob Jones we have not burned
the place down quite yet
we'll save enough at the end of the
livestream remember in the whole office
at the end we need more onion I think
that one cool veto all right I'm gonna
go on Dish duty after this look around
of plates start bringing these over so
the rest will be on you for a bit
John asks how much is it ten bucks Wow
alright the soup is ready is is their
dish yep Don and I will bring it over
third and which cooking was this easy at
home I know right putting three chopped
up three gigantic mushrooms and then you
make a soup and this is a I'm gonna
watch this one Chris crisis asking to
how long we're gonna stream for probably
for the next hour or so we'll see how
far we can actually get cuz the
gentleman here has actually beaten the
game so he's he's a pro at this he says
I just pick up the thing after it's done
mostly yeah yeah we've got all the stars
how do you stream on switch you just got
a you can you could stream the way you
stream any console through HDMI you just
have to be docked you can't do it hand
help I'm gonna get what happened we took
so long the tomato is going on ball we
got the onion for the next time right
yeah next time good onions ready okay
yeah the tomatoes I think it's gonna be
a lost cause so I'm snicker with more
onions okay we can probably do one more
no plea and they're not chopping okay
get that last one
take that like a mortem you don't if you
wanna try to get it tomato in time you
can get 20 seconds all right last one
that's gonna be close Jerry I don't know
we just didn't wait I'm gonna get out of
this is going to happen right here Oh
Joey you're not gonna make it no put it
back I can just pick up the plate oh man
to star Oh star party we could have made
me actually did it if you had gotten I
know okay the ring oh yeah wheelchair
raccoon so inclusive no they have they
have a panda as well I think also a
lizard think of me the DLC most because
I don't remember the lizard but that
must be deal see I did not actually play
all the DLCs so dude teal'c's is the DLC
is hard oh okay yeah it's that - star
life that Easter life yep okay cut meat
Joey plate buns what's the gimmick here
it's just
oh wait cuz that's gonna stay on this
type of them I remember the gimmick now
yes this gimmick sucks oh man
well you can't you can't toss me a now
oh you guys do that beforehand yeah oh
man Joey like that that one meats gonna
burn you can serve it right away throw
the meat over here I'm gonna plate that
Oh chop up as much as I can
first yeah the real problem isn't the
dishes because they're over here and
those over there yeah yeah
all right it's gonna go up or down it
always goes up yeah there's plate oh I
know that one meat take off the burner
for me all right do we need more lettuce
we need tomato wonderful oh no shoot
it's fine it's like burgers man I got
home a toe serve that burger
no I got oil all right
washee-washee okay we need more meets
I'm gonna stay up here so it doesn't
otherwise it would burn put it on that
one Joey okay all the lettuce is down
here damn it
here throw the plates down for me I
can't do that hey place down there we go
okay Josh Shaw says this is a good name
for a stream but why only two players
because we can only fit so many people I
would love to have more people I think
we're all really busy today just come on
we need a bun
what tomato I need tomato
please grab some plates moved on okay
maybe we wait okay let's let's think
about what we need at this point and me
a plate unique mom yeah put that in
there okay so start choppin that meat we
need meat badge okay give me those
plates too oh yeah grab more meat let's
get least two burgers going wait
surprised they don't make us toast the
buns a little much oops
okay well I'm down here now that's fine
okay like why is this one to have no
I've no Josh Shaw says this should have
been game of the year Josh I fought for
this real hard during our game of the
year actually it was pretty surprised
exactly how many people were vouching to
keep it like in 25 I think yeah I fought
really hard and then at the end I did
not win I was I was down Oh
Joey you can get it already cooked no
edge just finished does that space have
enough room for a couch it might it's
just that we're gonna be very small here
Josh I always loved hated those game in
your fights yeah I'm with you I love
them but I hate them it's really
doughnut hole says this is very
interesting for some reason so keep on
going or entertaining sorry entertaining
entertaining a combination of
interesting and entertaining oh I can
drive you
onion cabin is this it's the interlude
where you talk to the guy
oh that was it listen king onion onion
King the onion King so what was the
story behind overcooked
I know I like a portion of it like food
devil has come in the apocalypse is
happening and you have to get really
good yeah you have to go back in time to
get really good at cooking yeah travel
it's such a that is a great premise yeah
we go back to 1995
we all just cooperated yeah when cooking
was as peak hello dog okay max Viper
three five nine seven nine says did this
win a bunch of British Game of the Year
awards I know I want quite a few Awards
like in the indie scene and also for
like a lot a lot of outlets gave it like
best multiplayer like experience or best
co-op experience
well actually I want to change my guy
[ __ ] so that was the argument people
used against me was that because it can
only be played multiplayer and that the
single in that it has the single blur
but the single-player sucks and I'm like
what did we give Game of the Year -
overwatch a multiplayer only game yeah
Oh God Oh this one sucks okay yeah this
one's gonna be amazing
oh you have a fire extinguisher here I
remember that okay I'm going I'm going
go go go there you go whew all right I'm
staying over here on the ground I'm
gonna plate Oh Joey Oh Oh
I believe I can pro skills man just just
wait man they don't care that I throw
this on the floor right no that's fine
a sanitary it's not cooked you're gonna
cook it so you're gonna cook all the
germs off you know that's how that works
so I just prepare all my food like a
hole on the ground you're gonna cook it
anyway come on that's good lettuce I
keep forgetting that you don't need to
like a mash the button in order to cut
yeah it's gotta hold it I mean I have a
raccoon and I care about the sanity
exactly thank you
good no nope that's gone
[Music]
[Music]
and there you go Oh pick it up pick it
up please burning I got it oh boy this
is like the best level here let us help
stop I'm just like grabbing and chopping
anything go near I'm right okay my
character is having a hard time making
sense okay about to run out I think I
have it though yes I do and then I have
this perfect have that I just don't have
meat for oh you know why I never noticed
all blamers above the burgers really
yeah it's like essential man especially
the later half
maybe she's because I didn't get to get
as far to like actually worry about the
time that much right okay
vipir says they got this game yesterday
and the single player is insane oh dude
you got to have a person so their plan
is to play it and play that and mess of
others switch games at the next game
night that's a really good idea that's
yeah yeah only one of the best like ouch
go where it's like it's actually one of
them like of the few like really good
couch ball games out now
they're kind of hard to come by nowadays
we got 45 seconds prioritize hey can't
get this over to you in time yeah but
we'll see
[Music]
dude don't worry about it I like your
hustle Joey I also want some of it set
up pick nope
pick it up ah it's okay we got 216 I
find the controls they I feel like
they're weird that would have made a
difference in our star rating
all right yeah we're going very Marie
next
- -
well as James says as hectic as I
imagine would be to plates rather
relaxing to watch especially with the
background music yeah the music's great
I also I feel like there's just
something like satisfying about watching
food being cooked yeah when you're doing
it efficiently it's like wow that's
really satisfying so really don't holes
that says if you haven't you should try
snipper clips actually super clips is
fun I yeah play their players again have
you have you tried four players nipper
clip - I try it with you for like an or
play anyway I'm kind of crazy I remember
making that gameplay clip with you but
it was awful just people trying to look
at fit into shapes joy this is where the
rats show up whoo you keep food around
too long rats come and take it
okay so be efficient okay that's an
onion I don't need that yeah see rats
are gonna start taking this hey hey yep
told you can't take it back from okay
here's here's how I find they don't take
stuff on the pot so the second you chop
something just throw it in the pot or I
smacked it out from them so chop it
throw it in the pot okay then you put
the pot on the burner smart
onion we don't actually need another why
I could start cooking this onion just
let them take it it's okay I got that I
gotta go
then you gotta wash dishes to have this
one's rough oh my god
Oh Joey here yeah I'm over here yeah put
the bed on the one on now don't worry
about take it plate that other one rats
in our kitchen I'll put I'll deliver it
you put that other one yep nailed it you
don't need this tomato tomato
also Funyun these
come on put in there we go
kitchen is this the brats running around
no despite the fact that they like Koons
that tomato cats in here as well this
onion gonna be we're gonna get this on
you time I think so
let's forgot about this other onion
we've been this one we were doing very
efficiently we have yeah we could do
this one a lot better need tomato tomato
start cutting oh there we go wait into
the stressful this game this too
I don't know we're gonna make that
mushroom that's fine plate
yeah just give them the pot yeah more
for your money more Tomatoes more
mushroom okay tomato in mushroom yeah
okay if the lines of communication open
what do we need tomato tomato we don't
know mushroom okay no hand me another
one take your mushroom I can't
over here plate that we're not got time
okay mushroom sure you see you didn't
fail right hundred twenty points
mister super pancakes man says do you
guys play minecraft i play minecraft in
a while ever played it really like never
start that one's hard
I remember that one being with the
harder ones for me I know that we always
like hop open a minecraft server every
uh for extra life the life which is
always cool and we open it up for the
community and they they get in there
like build a bunch of like really cool
pixel stuff lots of minions last time
the entire hospital that we were I blame
I point to you I blend the UK for that
one that's all them what game is this is
overcoat
guys this game is overcooked it's the oh
this one you we're separated you have to
use a conveyor belt oh yeah
so the overcooked is the four-player
co-op cooking game that was released
last year for ps4 PC and Xbox one I
believe and it just came out for switch
yesterday okay let's keep you on all
right Johnny I'm gonna hand you meat
all right and I need you to cut the
weights for the meat I want you to send
those meats back to me okay cool perfect
here is yeah those are cooking just send
me all the the veggies I'll bring them
send it back to you you can keep those
veggies on the plates
yeah just put buns and veggies there you
go first one is just a meatless oh it's
just meat were starting out Mila some
veggie --less okay give me one more bun
then also need tomato
oh sorry
hey guy he answered start serving that
stuff but don't have lettuce or no no
bun take that bun put it there
and put on that meat and serve it the
first one Joe the first one okay okay
what do you need from me everything just
I have a I have a lettuce burger right
here it's ready to go okay know what
tomato
okay well that will have to wait
plates coming your way as well all right
after clean
though there
there yeah there's a plate for you hang
up meet need some lettuce and some more
lettuce and
Pandy use coming your way
all right there's a meet with a plate
all ready for you lettuce tomato there's
any because wondering alright doesn't
know how we're playing this game without
yelling at each other not yet not yet
what's Ryan tryin to be concentrate just
a little bit now if we were playing with
four players it'd be a whole whole
nother story
alright yeah that's what gets really
chaotic okay okay I need a date Joey
just deliver those right now you can
deliver them over the next one wait go
cool 166 all right Bob Jim says you guys
are good at working together thank you
uh only two stars oh yeah we're not that
great for about 50 minutes now wow the
time really flew by no please that's
what happens when you cook
let's do one more of these why don't we
then pop into the DLC which is
apparently really hard yeah and let it
psyche there's a Christmas one and then
there's like a tropical island one
let's see those a because I bet those
wanna see the yelling at each other
maybe yeah I don't know if I've done
festive seasoning sure yeah James Harris
no no yelling equals only one or two
stars yell four three stars remember
Barry says you they want to see have you
seen he's a kitchen nightmare show now
that's like there's so many crazy people
come out of the woodwork in or and show
like how terrible they are at running
restaurants right
I'm just yeah
[Music]
all right game for go we have like a
snow plow or something okay oh yes
Christmas in July
okay Joey let's do it
ben says he's a fantastic cook he just
wants that for the record Ben I would
love for you to cook me a meal I want to
see you make some soup with just three
Tomatoes just cut three tomatoes right
in that pot come on come on Vincent's
Gordon Ramsay follow them on Twitter he
should be mmm yes would you do so got an
onion a carrot and the potato whoo it's
not bad okay okay so Oh that's water
over there oh okay
so let's test it out first
today tato okay onion onion the onion in
and put this no no no no no Joe you got
to read it oh whoops
you messed up you gotta throw that out
no it's fine it's fine no oh no oh no no
oh it's sliding now oh boy okay you put
into the other pot first let me do that
here you got a cha okay I got rid of it
onion froze yes the potato okay hand me
that potato I'm gonna put it in there me
that carrot onion
here's an onion and one more potato
here's another potato okay okay that's
this one's ready oh my god
grab that potato and there's you know I
serve that other one ready yeah yeah
[Music]
parrot okay so that yeah that this is
tricky Skepta no attention it's not a
good hander trophy three two three
potatoes in there something my god
there's so many carrots plate okay
[Music]
chew on to onion two onions a carrot and
a potato
okay
hand me that chopstick here does oh god
no
[Music]
boom okay who built this place carrot
the carrot bad thing I don't think we're
gonna survive that suit I need a plate
Joey plate it and serve it
why fell how did I fall okay I think we
should look ahead yeah see what what
needs to be done after this okay
two onions a carrot and potato okay put
those onions in there Daniels put that
potato in because two carrots and onions
in that one or the ones early on nope
- got 3d plates shoot
[Music]
two carrots like God what are we making
right now I don't even know I need that
one that one
which one the two characters in that
onion Oh Joey put it don't oh I was
gonna say just drop it so it doesn't fit
all Oh and now it's gonna burn right
nope you're good
get on there sick tater I need that
potato
okay I'm just gonna put a ton of
vegetables on the counter have that one
Joey you deserve it
[Music]
I have nothing to do play do some
housekeeping I guess okay here it carrot
potatoes give me another carrot potato
carrot cool hand me that pot put it
right there
what's this one we need to put this one
on the burner yeah we also want yeah but
I'll give you that carrot onion one okay
what's that one it's gonna be ready in
there ready take it go gray 130 okay
told me peanut says I can totally see my
girlfriend I clean each other over this
well ask this guy because he did that
exact thing I don't know about the
killing part but uh there were there was
like a night or two rooms like okay
let's get the most part need to back up
a little bit think about what we're
doing that was hard
what's really hard we got a reindeer
that is cool though
that was worth it
Douglas Melinda says I hate penguins
because they can't even fly no that's
sweet
okay
paces try what this would look like it's
more soup more soup don't try the other
yeah let's go let's go the last morsel
yeah I haven't tried that one yet
now this not that one might be more
difficult yeah even more difficult let's
do it got like one more in s we should
we should do one more so let's do lots
more sauce
so if you guys are just joining us we
have been playing overcooked for the
switch it just came out yesterday and I
believe we're gonna be finishing up the
stream here with the last morsel which
is one of the DLC packs that comes with
the game see how it's not gonna be good
she plays body kinda notice that that's
really cool I like it's a dog dogs
normal
I'm sure it's a helicopter oh yeah this
looks annoying let's do it
oh boy okay it looks like the later
stuff like Pete says and you know
oh there's pizzas okay eventually gonna
make pizzas that means I've not gone
that far
chicken oh man are we making burritos
yes oh I like the burritos it doesn't
even tell us what we're doing
it's cuz it assumes you know music oh
yeah just gotta boil them right so what
do I do it for kids in people on the
plate oh you got fried this chicken Joey
I need you to grab that chicken before
it falls where is it it goes in the
trash
oh my goodness
yeah why don't start please some of
these 40 is a we have rice yeah oh
you're cooking right now why is it Brad
browning browning the rice in like a mud
gu baskets ever put grits on a pizza
no that chicken there boom serve that
yeah okay I need some meat
okay oh no damn it okay
you have a breed oh I see I'm gonna yeah
you have a plea for it yeah two burritos
who's done so far jump it chicken right
there there you go do that rice and rice
it meets almost brown over on the side
here's some plates right here because do
dishes right and also need a plate okay
that rice cooked
rice tortilla oh I need for Tia just
serve this one real quick okay and that
rice okay on the plate with rice on it
yep leave some chicken coming up all
right
chicken chicken chicken
just got the photo put your chicken here
maybe one chicken three plates hopefully
get there in time please
yeah I got some chicken on a plate if
they get rice looking to me I'd I need
to boil rice oh yeah they oh yeah we
always want to have the pots going just
filled with something you plate you
please thank you tortilla give me a
tortilla Joey that wasn't too bad
I feel like we could have been a little
bit more efficient but it didn't seem
like we were struggling spicy meat that
was got that's good it was good Oh miss
Angelique says on Pizza do they make you
do that I think that's a Canadian thing
it's not a Canadian thing we do it here
in America
they do not make you put pineapple on
pizza just to stir the pot yeah Bob just
says that look like a failure to three
stars so some of the later levels are
like that where you're you're just like
oh man we did bad but it's like no
actually did pretty good
I just felt bad it felt bad but why the
conveyer belts
yeah the conveyor belts get really tough
especially levels like that where it's
like if you leave it on the conveyor
belt too long it just goes right into a
trash can yeah who designed this kitchen
oh boy
yeah I think that's gonna do it for
overcooked what's the call here I could
look at the name it's called overcook
special edition available on today or
yesterday on the switch for 20 bucks
mm-hmm which is pretty good because this
is a great game and yeah let's get this
game like pretty much every system yeah
so if you all have a switch if you have
PC ps4 Xbox anything sure they'll port
it to other
things like Linux Mac sure maybe why not
but yeah that's so that's gonna do it
for us you know we have a little bit
shorter stream this week um but we will
be here every Friday along with all the
other streams that we have throughout
the week you know every weekday we
stream at 11 a.m. yep me and John Luke
are here every Friday yeah tune in next
Friday we got cool thing we're gonna try
very excited about it don't hype it up
too much okay I'm guy but above all it's
so good it's kinda it's it's the coolest
thing we've ever done ever on this
entire site I think so I agree with that
very excited about it right thanks guys
all right see you guys next week